for Corey I expected more I expected to
finish it you can't beat the Gap too
much you're talking about your torn
tricep it's a big big deal man but yeah
he played it safe and and now there's
not a chance he's next in line for a
title shot unless there's like major
injuries probably two guys need to get
injured before they look his Direction I
would be willing to bet UFC's like all
right you're gonna fight new Martin
knock her Matt off next like we're not
we're not entertaining anything else but
that after a performance like that
because they know he can't take Umar
down like this and be forced to strike
with him so that's what they're gonna do